it has to be more clear yeah yeah you  know i think for both of you guys yes it  has to happen yeah like there's not like  there's no other way to settle this you  guys have to fight yeah we see what  happens i i look forward to it you know  whatever whatever comes comes we'd be  ready  we stay ready and i can't wait i think  for the legacy of alex the great  i think we need a a [ __ ] stamp on the  max halloween  division that trilogy with max is what  everyone's talking about most people  probably want obviously in australia be  great so that's why i'd make that  decision and again right now we don't  have anyone else no clear number one  until someone does that people are gonna  keep throwing max's name out there so  right now we would want that we would  want our next fight what's going to be  the best pay-per-views what's what does  everyone want  and right now a lot of the a lot of  that's point in the match  they don't see the pay